[Musique]
enfin
bonsoir mesdames bon sens mesdemoiselles
bonsoir messieurs sans oublier bien sûr
les enfants qui nous regardent dans soir
gérard c'est bien mon choix aux enfants
et aux parents et aux parents j'ai tout
dit non j'ai cependant quelque chose à
rajouter ajouté plus exactement nous
avons reçu de très nombreuses lettres de
téléspectateurs mécontents parce qu'ils
nous ont envoyé un truc et que ce truc
est bien représentée par une autre
personne
alors nous nous en excusons bien sûr
mais nous vous rappelons que nous avons
reçu plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
lettres dans lesquelles nous retrouvons
ce même truc alors il faut donc faire un
choix est ce choix bien nous l'avons
confiée au hasard par tirage au sort
comme nos six nouveaux candidats
d'ailleurs ils ont été tirés au sort
je vous les présente dans quelques
secondes auparavant je voudrais vous
signaler que le sucre d intégrer grimpe
il vaut 600 francs et un tout nouveau
truc appartenant à monsieur cugn ans de
paris la boîte ensorcelé 300 francs
bonsoir candidats de numéro 1 votre nom
madame meunier de paris vous êtes sûr
candidats libéraux de monsieur
charbouillot philippe de lure
quand il atteint 0,3 à nous à la paire
de paris candidat numéro 4 monsieur
bruce donc de notre candidat numéro cinq
sur bordeaux 2 nice est candidate numéro
6 nm aubril de versailles ensemble nous
regardons le sucre se désintégrer il
vaut je vous le rappelle 600 francs un
truc avec 3 sucre c3 sucre sont placés
dans la main gauche et maintenant je
retire l'un d'eux que je pose sur la
table il reste dessus
un simple mouvement comme cela sur les
doigts l'un des sucres a disparu il n'en
reste plus qu'un quel est le truc qui
permet cette désintégration mademoiselle
meunier une question à poser à gérard
est ce que le sucre est mouillé c'est
ingérable il faut poser la question
non madame ne se connaît pas mouillé
candidat numéro 2 messieurs charbouillot
est-ce que vous ne voyez que de sucre à
là on se rapproche oui on n'emploie que
de sucre je pense que vous mettez un
sucre horizontalement
l'eau sertic allemand et comment voit-on
3 sucre alors monsieur bien comme je
peux le faire
oui venez venez je vous en prie asseyez
vous voilà à 38 donc vous n'en voulez
que deux pour votre solution
deux seulement très bien alors présenté
attendez on est présente dans ce sens là
monsieur alors là maintenant comment
faites vous oui mais une raie au milieu
avec un objet dur répéter bien fort fait
une raie au milieu des cannes objet dur
de façon qui on envoie 3 attendez j'ai
dans la poche quelques petites choses
préparées là est ce qu'il s'agit de cela
monsieur quelque sorte c'est ça que vous
vouliez fait oui vous avez gagné ils
tremblent monsieur parle pas avec vous
tremblez la mesure un petit peu mais
faut pas tremblé puisque au contraire
vous avez gagné qu'à regarder vous avez
trouvé le sucre comme cela et vous avez
bien dit horizontalement faisant une
marque au milieu ce qui fait quand le
tenant mais vous allez me faire vous
même pour nos amis vous allez le tenir
monsieur montrer les trois avec la main
droite
à ma droite voilà retenez bien comme
cela
vous montrez les trois sucre sanguin
un avec la le truc pour monsieur pour
l'instant c'est les garder en main qui
tombent pas parce que en tremblant comme
il le fait c'est difficile
alors monsieur fait le montrez votre
main gauche vous tenez retirée sans un
donc vous retirer celui qui est marqué
par exemple vous allez faire le
contraire et vous montrer la main où il
est entier n'est plus là tout seul que
vous avez gagné monsieur bravo hein
bravo il ya un truc
félicitations monsieur félicitations
veni tenez absolument me disais depuis
départ au cas où vous auriez gagné à
vous faire une bise en malaisie que vous
avez gagné 6 en france surtout
voilà monsieur et nous regardons tout de
suite le deuxième truc la boîte
ensorcelé qui vaut 300 francs qui
appartient à monsieur qu'union de paris
[Musique]
gérard cugn ans est éducateur et fait
souvent des tours aux enfants
aujourd'hui nous en montre à cette boîte
d'allumettes obéi aux ordres de même je
vais la placer sur ce gobelet renversé
voilà elle est en équilibre elle est en
équilibre
regardez bien même ces mouvements doit
son spécial à la boîte les comprend elle
ne peut résister à leurs impulsions
l'arrivée à attirer la boîte
absolument et la boîte tombe grâce à ce
one man mais écoutez vous ferez croire
cela à qui vous voulez moi je sais que
vous avez un truc et il s'agit de le
trouver
mademoiselle appert candidat numéro 3 la
façon de poser la boîte est important la
façon de poser la doit oui oui la façon
de poser la boîte et d'importantes n'ai
pas de solution messieurs bruit parce
qu'il n'y aurait pas un cheveu coincé la
boîte d'allumettes et qu'on tirait
dessus vous avez un mouvement de
monsieur kenyan tiré nettement
il tourne mais ce qui nous tire vous
parlez d'un cheveu non il ne s'agit pas
d'un cheveu non monsieur bourle de nice
mais est-ce qu'il s'agit pas simplement
là mais n'a rien à voir dans l'histoire
c'est un coup de genou dans la tam qui
fit basculer la ola
pain ou un très léger vous savez on en
serait pas sûr or le truc que vous
indique monsieur client permet de le
faire à tous les coups et un coup de
genou vous savez on peut aimer ça fait
peut-être sauter la boîte en l'air qui
avait tomberait aussi lui même c'est un
régime qui cherche centre et vous savez
que quand on enregistre vous devez
savoir que sur le plan technique le
moindre petit son est perceptible et la
non non il s'agit pas d'une candidate
numéro 6 madame aubry non je ne veux pas
les bonnes questions à poser à gérard
vous le voyez aurait peut-être une
histoire des démons peut-être à un
aimant un aimant qui serait ou madame
enfin je ne sais pas est ce qu'il ya un
aimant vous voulez des noms et le
mouvement si des fois attend des aimants
au mouvement
vous parlez de quoi en faisant le
mouvement si des fois la boîte
tendez votre geste m'explique pas ce que
voulait dire en faisant le mouvement
quand on est aussi revenu les doigts si
la boîte j'ai pas avec les doigts que ça
coloré et ben ça colle pas du tout non
c'est pas ça
ça colle très bien pour monsieur
qu'union puisque son truc augmente et
demandera pas pardon excusez moi madame
madame meunier excusez moi vous n'avez
pas de solution vous êtes surjoue
bouscule un petit peu excusez moi à la
difficile c'est difficile
oui c'est vrai monsieur l'union c'est
que je connais par ailleurs est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas facile du tout
est quelque chose qui l'attirent dont
les douanes
c'est pas sur les doigts de quel ordre
il le dit lui-même que c'est par ses
doigts par son mouvement qui l'attirent
la boîte est ce qu'il est sincèrement je
n'en sais rien je ne porte la gare
hambourg médias
mais vous ne voyez pas eh bien madame
nous regrettons et je tiens d'ailleurs
pour nos amis que les spectateurs à leur
dire d'envoyer des tours de ce genre là
car voilà un tour original qui ne
ressemble à rien d'autre et qu'on a vu
encore nulle part monsieur qu'une y en a
eu de l'initiative et je crois que son
tour est très difficile à trouver et en
tout cas oui vous l'avez vous pouvez
nous écrire
bien sûr au juillet un truc 158 rue de
l'université 75007 341 paris cedex 07
nos deux trucs donc la boîte ensorcelé
appartenant à monsieur cugn en 600
francs et à tous nouveaux trucs la pièce
sauteuse 300 francs au revoir et votre
soirée
[Musique]
gérard cugn ans et éducateurs et fait
souvent des tours aux enfants
aujourd'hui nous en montre à cette boîte
d'allumettes obéi aux ordres de même je
vais la placer sur ce gobelet renversé
voilà elle est en équilibre elle est en
équilibre
regardez bien même ces mouvements de
doigts sont spéciaux à la la boîte les
comprend elle ne peut résister à leurs
impulsions vous arrivez à attirer la
boîte
absolument et la boîte tombe dans le
stationnement
mais écoutez vous ferez croire cela à
qui vous voulez moi je sais que vous
avez un truc et il s'agit de le trouver
[Musique]
voici un truc avec une bouteille
transparente et une pièce de 5 centimes
qui épousait sur le goulot le truc est
simple on placer main sur la bouteille
et on en donne à la pièce de sauter
alors regardez bien cette pièce elle se
soulève et saute encore une fois s'il
vous plaît merci
et bien ce truc est très simple encore
il n'y a pas de rythme et de trucs qui
permettent ce résultat bonne année bonne
santé
à bientôt 1 l'année prochaine
[Musique]